Hi, everybody, it's Paul.
You know, a lot of people ask me,...
...after a long day of voice-over or writing...
...or doing all those creative things that I do,...
...how do I relax?
Well, like many other Americans, I come home and I pet my dog.
You see, petting your dog...
...is one of the most relaxing things you can possibly do.
It releases a hormone called oxytocin, which reduces stress.
Also, it lowers your heart rate and it lowers your blood pressure.
Plus, people who pet their dogs...
...are five times more likely to live longer...
...than people who just have cats.
Plus, the dogs like it so much.
And that's a nice bonding experience.
That's right.
Who's Daddy's little boy?
Daddy's little boy.
That's right.
Okay, we're done.